SOME MORE RESTRICTION RULES
WOULD STAY IN PLACE.
>> Sandra: FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
BYRON YORK.
GREAT TO SEE YOU HERE.
YOUR BIG 2022 MIDTERM, YOUR
PROJECTION FOR THE KEY WINNERS
IN THE UPCOMING ELECTION IN A
MOMENT.
FIRST THE TOP ISSUES, YOU HEARD
LINDSEY GRAHAM THERE, THIS IS
PUTTING OBVIOUSLY WITH 50 PLUS
DAYS OUT ABORTION, FRONT AND
CENTER.
YOU'VE GOT CRIME, IMMIGRATION,
AND YOU'VE GOT INFLATION THAT
REPORT LAST WEEK WAS A STUNNER.
I MEAN, 8.3% INFLATION, YOU'VE
GOT THE AVERAGE AMERICAN PAYING
13.5% GROCERY INFLATION IN THE
COUNTRY, WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE
TOP ISSUE FOR VOTERS?
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT WHEN THIS
IS ALL OVER WE MIGHT SEE LAST
WEEK, LAST TUESDAY WHEN THE
INFLATION NUMBERS CAME OUT, AS A
TURNING POINT IN THIS MIDTERM
RACE BECAUSE THERE'S NO DOUBT
DEMOCRATS HAD BEEN MOVING UP
DOING MUCH, MUCH BETTER ON A FEW
ISSUES, THE SO-CALLED GENERIC
BALLOT WAS GETTING CLOSER, THEY
PULLED AHEAD, THINGS WERE
LOOKING GOOD FOR THEM AND THEN
THE INFLATION NUMBERS TOLD
EVERYBODY THAT INFLATION WAS A
CHRONIC, A PERSISTENT PROBLEM,
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY, NOT VERY
MUCH BETTER.
THE LATEST FOX NEWS POLL WE SEE,
IF YOU COMBINE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY ARE MOST
CONCERNED, TOP ISSUE ABOUT
INFLATION WITH THOSE WHO ARE
MOST CONCERNED ABOUT JOBS AND
THE ECONOMY, THREE REALLY
RELATED TOPICS, YOU GET 35%.
NUMBER MOST CONCERNED ABOUT
ABORTION IS 16%, LESS THAN HALF
THAT.
SO REPUBLICANS ARE FEELING MORE
CONFIDENT THIS WEEK THAN A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO, THAT INFLATION
WILL INDEED REMAIN THE TOP ISSUE
AND THAT HELPS THEM IN THE RACE.
>> Sandra: THE POLL YOU
MENTIONED WE HAVE ON THE SCREEN
THERE, INFLATION, 19%.
THEY SAY THAT IS THE BIGGEST
ISSUE MOTIVATING THEM AS VOTERS
RIGHT NOW, BUT TO YOUR POINT IF
YOU COMBINE THAT WITH JOBS AND
THE ECONOMY, THEY ARE NOT REALLY
SEPARATE ISSUES, YOU'RE POLLING
TWICE THAT OF THOSE WHO SAY
ABORTION IS THE TOP ISSUE,
BYRON.
WHAT IS YOUR BIG 2022 FORECAST?
>> WELL, I THINK THE NEWS IS
BASICALLY WHAT IT'S ALWAYS BEEN,
WHICH IS THE HOUSE -- THE
REPUBLICANS ARE IN A VERY, VERY,
VERY GOOD POSITION TO TAKE THE
HOUSE.
I MEAN, JUST NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
HISTORICALLY, THE ISSUES, ALL OF
THAT.
IT LOOKS VERY GOOD FOR
REPUBLICANS.
AS FAR AS THE SENATE IS
CONCERNED, IT'S BEEN IMPOSSIBLE
TO PREDICT ANYTHING WITH THE
SENATE, ALTHOUGH IT IS TRUE THAT
A COUPLE RACES, ESPECIALLY
PENNSYLVANIA, SEEM TO BE GETTING
CLOSER AND THAT MEANS
REPUBLICANS RISING A BIT.
DR. OZ RISING TOWARD EATING INTO
THE JOHN FETTERMAN LEAD.
SO, IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE AT ALL
THAT REPUBLICANS COULD WIN BACK
THE SENATE.
BUT AS FAR AS THE HOUSE IS
CONCERNED, LOOKING REALLY SOLID
FOR THEM RIGHT NOW.
>> Sandra: DARRELL ISSA WAS HERE
LAST WEEK AND MAKING SURE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MAKING THOSE TYPE OF
PROJECTIONS KNOW EVEN IF
REPUBLICANS PULL OFF A VICTORY
IN THE HOUSE, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
MARGIN WHICH THEY PULL OFF
VICTORY IS GOING TO BE KEY
BECAUSE YOU COULD HAVE SOME OF
THOSE REPUBLICANS THAT DO
EVENTUALLY PULL OFF VICTORY NOT
SUPPORTING THE ESTABLISHMENT.
SO IF THEY ARE GOING TO GET
ANYTHING DONE IN THE HOUSE,
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE A
PRETTY HEFTY MARGIN OF VICTORY.
TO THAT YOU SAY WHAT, BYRON.
>> NO, YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
A MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE IS 218
SEATS.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO GET ALL
THOSE PEOPLE TO AGREE ON EVERY
SINGLE THING, JUST NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
TO REALLY EFFECTIVELY GOVERN, A
PARTY NEEDS A MAJORITY IN WHICH
THEY CAN LOSE 5, 10, MAYBE EVEN
A DOZEN MORE MEMBERS AND STILL
WIN.
SO, THE IDEA -- YOU KNOW,
REPUBLICANS WIN THE HOUSE WITH
219, 220 SEATS, IT'S BARELY ANY
MAJORITY AT ALL.
IT'S BETTER THAN NOT WINNING THE
HOUSE, BUT IT'S A REALLY TINY,
TINY MAJORITY.
THEY GET 235, 240, SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
IT'S A MUCH MORE GOVERNABLE
MAJORITY.
>> Sandra: INTERESTING.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON